hi I'm montréal and CEO of magnetic and
I'm speaking to hear live from the World
Economic Forum summer Davos in dalian
china delighted to be here question I've
been asked for comments is will China
pull us out of the economic crisis and I
think that if with such a global economy
and the saurians connected that there's
no one country that can actually pull us
out of any form of crisis I think this
is something that we can joined together
sort of pulled ourselves down and we can
join together sort of pull ourselves up
but i think if one looks at just getting
out of the crisis in general i'd like to
really highlight and enforces them the
real thing that helps together the
prices and helps growing is innovation
so the needs to systematically be new
things with their business processes
business models and you product new
technologies it is that creation of
innovation is that focus on innovation
and I think it is very important is that
countries and companies and I do not
lose the focus and innovation continue
to invest in innovation I think China is
a good example of a country that is
really trying to be more and more
innovative and make more investments but
at the same time clearly Europe the
United States for a huge track record
innovation so I think then we'll try to
pull us out of the economic crisis no
not by itself we'll all have to pull
ourselves out but the thing overall the
pulling ourselves of innovations so
thank for giving the opportunity thanks